- Wait, you did something special though
with your daughters when
you and Trisha got married
and I thought this was
the sweetest thing ever.
- Well, they got married.
So, Trisha doesn't have children.
So they got married.
They exchanged rings and
said vows to each other
because I told 'em, "If
something happens to me,
"you gotta take care of the queen.
"You gotta take care of Miss Yearwood."
And it was great.
We were at the dinner, all three of 'em,
it was a really tight
conversation, I'm nervous,
and I finally work up the courage to say,
I'd like to get married and
they were all fine with it.
I said, "But you gotta take care of her."
And I'm waitin' for something
intelligent to come back
and it was the youngest, Allie, that said,
"We got your back, bra strap."
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
That was it.
That was the end of the conversation.
- Guess I'll have some
more cornbread, yeah.
That's like awesome.
(Garth laughs)